hi we know that in specific antigen
there are small portions of the antigen
for example here marked in blue which is
going to be recognized by the antibody
whether its membrane bound b-cell
receptor or a secreted antibody and this
small portion in the large protein is
known as the epitope now inside the
whole protein there could be multiple
different epitope right and sometimes
one epitope could be selectively
detected by one class of antibodies and
that class of antibodies might not
detect any other epitope shown here so
that category of antibody could be
termed as monoclonal antibody now other
antibodies which are going to detect
many of these epitope at least few of
these epitope non-specifically they're
termed as polyclonal antibody and in
other video we would look at how
monoclonal antibody is generated
artificially now another important term
which is confusing or sometimes people
misunderstand that is per octave so
epitope is a part of the antigen a small
part of the antigen which is going to be
presented to the t-cell receptor or the
P cell receptor that is the epitope of
an antigen but a para top is that part
of the antibody which is interacting
with the epitope so definitely para tope
resides in the variable region of the
antibody the variable region pericope
consists of the hyper variable loop loop
which is going to directly interact with
the epitope so that's how we just kind
of explain the terminologies of epitope
and para tube in this video for short
video thank you if you like my video
even a thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you